what will this storm due to natural gas
well first of all you know we gotta
didn't play this down a little bit late
yesterday afternoon with two feet are so
in Boston but not much more than a foot
in New York City but that doesn't really
affect the market that much natural gas
is actually up today because we're
seeing more colder storms on the way
about 5 10 15 days from now so with a
short position in the market right now
speculators heavily short the market I
think we're going to reverse and we'll
see higher prices do professionals trade
a blizzard you know if they do they're
making mistakes because usually it's
very short with effect on the commodity
market sometimes it has more effect and
equities for example generac which is a
generating company you know people by
generators to heat their homes and power
goes out that's up five percent since
yesterday where as well the energy
markets actually we're down the one
thing that you can do during a blizzard
if you see two or three in a row is by
heating oil and sell crude or by eating
alone sell gasoline as people drive less
so that's one spread that probably will
work over the next couple weeks and you
wrote us an email last night Jim that
that you want to take another look at
utility stocks and basically that's the
old it's the old trick of buying on the
room or selling on the reality the
reality here today is very different
from the rumor yesterday that's exactly
right you know unless you have a winter
like last year we had you know five
snowstorms and idiots of snow in the in
the east and three months of incredible
cold weather that did affect the economy
and you know fourth quarter and first
quarter 2015 GDP or 14 GDP you're not
going to see anything that other than a
very short-term reaction so we got to
look at a longer-term trend where can we
find that right now possibly in the
natural gas market we're at historical
low levels currently we have cold
weather that I think will persist off
and on through March and the market very
oversold I think we'll begin the rally
Jim I would have assumed that the
utility companies have some kind of
insurance against natural and events no
yeah many them do I made them you know
by insurance policies through Lloyds you
know the biggest effect ever that I go I
saw I think in the bond market and also
utility stocks
where many companies had reinsurance was
during Hurricane Andrew back in 1992
which you know wiped out Florida Gulf
Coast was actually even more of an
impact in the commodity market and
Katrina was in some fashion all right
Jim Rome right thank you so much joining
us there a gym rumor who covers a
commodity market